[Upbeat Music]
My lab at NLM is studying the non-coding
part of the human genome.
When the human genome was sequenced in 2001, what we learned
is that only 2% of the sequence of our genome
is used for coding genes. That in turn translate into proteins.
This is the sequence informationthat's being used by every singlecell.
But it only represents 2% of our genome.98% of our DNA is not being used.
Therewere some speculation suggesting that
it could be that that large chunk of our genome
is purely junk and, in reality, that’s not true.
There are treasure islands, within the sea
of non-coding DNA in the human genome,
that are critically important for regulating the genes.
These are the pieces that wecan refer to as light switches.
What we’ve learned, is95%of disease associations,
they hide within thesenon-codingpart of our genomes.
And what my lab istrying to do is look
through these vast landscapesof the human genome
and identify where theselight switches arehiding
and to figure out what exactly do they do.
Which genes do theyturn on,
when do they turn these genes on,
and what happens if theydon’t turn these genes on?
So, if we want to understand
how we canaddress human diseases and disorders,
we have to study and to understand
the non-coding partof our genomes.
I still cannot comprehend how we can
conquer space, have self-driving cars,
and do not understand the encryption of the human genome.
I am really interested in trying to get to this hidden second code of ourgenomes
by the end of my scientific career.
[Music reaches a crescendo, then fades out]
[Silence]